so the store of Cain and Abel is of
course one of the most known in
Scripture
and so uh I thought that I would go over
the story with you to look at some of
the details to look at how it relates to
the left and the right that I've been
talking about in my most recent videos
but I also want to look at how there's a
reflection of this story and a few Pagan
myths and hopefully it would also help
you see the manner in which one can look
at other stories from other cultures
from other myths and how it can actually
give you hints about some of the
biblical structure it doesn't compromise
it it doesn't question the Integrity of
the biblical story but sometimes because
it follows similar patterns it can help
us see what is going on in the biblical
stories see things that we wouldn't have
noticed at first glance
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm going to read the story to start off
with and of course this I will not go
through all the details of the story
it's a very complex story I'm prompted
to do this in part because when I was in
London last week I uh I went on stage
with Jordan Peterson I needed spent the
whole time talking about Cain and Abel
and those of you know that um that
Jordan really loves that story and sees
it as a reflection of of deep you know
the the pattern of deep resentment which
exists in humans and uh he he wanted me
to do the Q a at the end and as he was
speaking I had these images of these
Street these three Pagan stories that
came up in my mind and so I asked him
about it in the Q a and he gave me his
answer so I'm hoping they're going to
publish the talk so you can hear what
Jordan's answer was but in the meantime
I will give you my own answer in my own
let's say uh intuitions about these
stories and how they all relate together
so we start in Genesis chapter 4. now
Adam knew Eve his wife and she conceived
and bore Cain and said I have acquired a
man from the Lord then she bore again
this time his brother Abel now Abel was
a keeper of sheep but Cain was a tiller
of the ground and in the process of time
it came to pass that Cain brought an
offering a fruit of the fruit of the
ground to the Lord Abel also brought of
the firstborn of his flock and of their
fat
and the Lord respected Abel and his
offering but he not he did not respect
Cain and his offering and Cain was very
angry and his countenance fell
so the Lord said to Cain why are you
angry and why has your countenance
Fallen if you do well will you not be
accepted and if you do not do well sin
lies at your door and his desire is for
you
but you should rule over it
now Cain talked with his with Abel's
brother and it came to pass
when they were in the field that Cain
rose up against Abel his brother and
killed him
then the Lord said to Cain where is Abel
your brother
he said I do not know am I My Brother's
Keeper
and he said what have you done
the voice of your brother's blood cries
out to me from the ground so now you are
cursed from the earth which has opened
its mouth to receive your brother's
blood and from your hand
when you till the ground it shall no
longer yield its strength to you a
fugitive in Vagabond you shall be on the
Earth
and Cain said to the Lord my punishment
is greater than I can bear surely you
have driven me out this day from the
fall of from the face of the ground I
shall be hidden from your face and I
shall be a fugitive and a vagabond on
the earth and it will happen that anyone
who finds me will kill me the Lord said
to him therefore whoever kills Cain
Vengeance shall be taken on him
Sevenfold and the Lord said a mark on
Cain lest anyone finding him should kill
him
then Kane went out from the presence of
the Lord and dwelt in the Land of Nod on
the East of Eden and Kane knew his wife
she conceived in bore Enoch and he built
the city and called the name of the city
after his son Enoch to Enoch was born
irad and irad jail
and mahuja will be caught methus shall
and methusel begotlamic so
let's keep going a little bit
thenlamic took for himself two wives the
name of one was ARA and the name of the
second was zeela and Arab or jabal and
he was the father of those who dwell in
tents and have livestock his brother's
name was Jubal he was the father of
those who play the harp and flute and as
for zela she also bore triple Kane an
instructor of every Craftsman in bronze
and iron and the sister of tubal Kane
was nama
then lamix edge with wives aranzila hear
my voice wives of lamech listen to my
speech for I have killed a man for
wounding me even a young man for hurting
me if Cain shall be Avenged Sevenfold
thenlamic 70 Sevenfold so of course this
story has many elements in it at first
when we look at it we noticed a few
things if you're interested in some of
the details of this I already made a
video called The Mark of Cain which
looks at the relationship between Cain
and civilization but a few things you
can notice is of course
the relationship of increase between
civilization the increase of
civilization the increase of the curse
and how these things go together that is
as Cain becomes a nomad and and sets up
a city which looks like a contradiction
but is not at all
he sets up a city he also sets up an
increase in power and he sets up at the
same time an increase of the curse with
his descendants all of these things are
there in the genealogy and the way in
which it sets itself up so of course as
I mentioned many times before this will
lead up to the flood as the final result
of this increase of
of the curse of Technology of evil in
the world uh all of these things are
going to increase now the first thing I
want to do with you is I want to look at
a few images of Cain and Abel and it'll
be interesting to notice the
relationship of the left and the right
hand that I mentioned in my different
videos and you'll see the different ways
in which it can be portrayed
and so here you have a version a few
versions of the um the sacrifice of Cain
and Abel now notice in each image one of
the things you have is you have able
who is on the side of the blessing that
is on the right side of the image he's
on the left side from our point of view
but on the right side from the point of
view of God who is represented as this
just uh dark Glory that moves into light
and through the hand of God here that
you can see here
and so the right hand is blessing if you
remember that I talked about how the
right hand has the blessing the right
hand of Christ and the icon of the uh
of the pantocretory so the right hand is
blessing Abel who's offering the
sacrifice you can see this represented
as a straight line of array of light or
array of blessing which comes down upon
the uh the um the lamb and you CA and if
you look carefully you'll notice that
above the land there's also a flame so
the fire is going up the blessing is
coming down and Cain here is being
ignored we could say in this image so
there are different ways of representing
it here you see now of course this is a
later image and so God is represented
completely which we won't talk about
here but you can see nonetheless that
God is represented here his hand is on
the right hand he's blessing Abel who is
down here his fire is going up towards
God
Kane is here God is looking away from
Cain and the fire of his of his
sacrifice is not going up it's coming
down towards below and so if you
remember again the images of the last
judgment how on the one side the right
side is going up the left side is going
down all of these things come together
here's just one more image one more
version one more way of representing it
which is interesting
here you again have Kane and able Abel
here and came here God Appears here of
course this seems to be Christ though
not sure he has a cross in his Halo and
so Christ appears above with his right
hand he is blessing Abel below and here
interestingly enough the the smoke from
Abel's sacrifice is going up but the
smoke from Able sacrifices is returning
on Cain it's turning back on him and
he's blinding him is going into his eyes
and making him blind at the very
powerful image of the left hand of the
the straight and the curved if you
remember I've talked about that in terms
of the for example the staff and the
Globus the different versions of this or
the staff and the snake you know if you
think about it that way the different
aspects uh of the the two the two sides
let's say
of the basic structure and so you can
see the right and the left hand
symbolism being represented very well
there now what I wanted to talk about is
I wanted to talk about
I want to bring up three Pagan myths and
so I'm going to tell you the Pagan myths
and then we're what we're going to do is
we're going to look at those Pagan myths
in with the frame of the biblical story
of Adam of Cain and Abel and what I'm
hoping is that it'll help you see how
you can actually use Pagan myths to
understand the Bible without without
feeling like it is compromising it or
questioning it but rather see it as as
these pattern stories that all are
participating in the same pattern seen
from different points of view over
different aspects of the same patterns
and so it can help you see a pattern in
Scripture that maybe you hadn't noticed
before
and so the first story I want to tell
you is the story of
Romulus and Remus so most of you will
know the story this is of course a Verge
a story an image of them when they were
very young and they were being suckled
by a she-wolf and so the story of of
Romulus and Remus is that both of these
brothers
find a place where they're going to find
a Sith they're going to found a city a
city which in the future will be come to
be will be Rome it will be the city of
Rome that they're going to to uh found
and so Romulus decides to trace the
limit of the city
and after he's traced the limits
sometimes built a wall or traced some
kind of limit his brother Remus
jumps over the wall basically questions
the limit that that Romulus is trying to
set as being the city and because of
that Romulus kills his brother
and then founds the city of Rome
so that is Story number one
now Story number two the Titan
Prometheus
who are
was one of the Titans as as as you know
the Titans are ambiguous characters in
the story they are sometimes seen as
gods that precede the uh the lineage of
Zeus or the gods that are under Zeus but
somehow have been pushed in the margins
they they they have a marginal existence
there are many versions of how this
there's a relationship to them uh to to
to the how Zeus is related to the Titans
that is probably the best way to
understand it is that there are these
these Gods which were there before
they're there on the margin they they're
related sometimes to the notion of the
Giants in general they're different
associations which come to be brought
together so Prometheus
is on the earth and as the humans are
offering a sacrifice to Zeus what
Prometheus does is that he tricks Zeus
usually for the sacrifice you would give
the best part to the God but what Zeus
what Prometheus does is that he takes
the bones of the animal and then puts
him on the Altar and hides the bones
with uh the skin of the animal and so
Zeus can't see what is being sacrificed
and Prometheus sacrifices the gives a
improper sacrifice we could say to Zeus
and so because of this improper
sacrifice Zeus decides to remove the
fire
the Divine fire that humans had the fire
that humans had to to warm themselves to
also create technology so Prometheus has
to you know climb up Mount Olympus and
steal the fire from the gods in order to
bring it down to humans and give it back
to humans
in doing so he becomes the patron of
Technology the patron of the different
crafts and is represented as such now
interestingly enough the image that I'm
showing you here is an image from the
Rockefeller Center in New York which is
a celebration of Prometheus
uh in the myth Prometheus is then uh
in the myth Prometheus is then punished
by Zeus for doing that he is tied to
Iraq and every day an eagle comes and
eats his liver importantly enough it's
good to understand that the liver for
the ancient Greeks was seen as the seed
of emotion we could understand it at
this as the seed of the passions may be
a good way to see it that way and so
Prometheus ends up in this cycle of the
passion because every day the ego comes
and eats his liver but then it grows
back again the next day and so by by
engaging in this Behavior Prometheus
falls into this cycle of passion
and of course the last story is the
story of hephestos so hephaestos is in
different versions sometimes he is the
son of Zeus and Hera sometimes he is a a
only a son of Hera that was that was uh
born without a relationship to a man
um that was kind of
almost like a virgin birth of of Hera
and
what happens though with this character
hephaestos is that at some point he acts
in an improper way we could also say
something like he he breaks he breaks
the rule he makes an improper sacrifice
and because of that he actually what he
tries to do is he tries to have a
relationship with his own mother and so
he tries to seduce or to rape or to you
know try to to have a sexual intercourse
with his mother and because of that he
is thrown out of paradise
he had thrown at his he is thrown out of
the mountain Olympus this mountain where
the gods live above and uh down into
Hades and now in Hades he becomes a
blacksmith and becomes the the great
artificer who Who develops all the
weapons and all the different the
different metal objects that the that
the the Greeks and the Greek gods use
so now if we think about these stories
which it's interesting to notice how
they come to be related to each other so
in the story of Cain and Abel
it doesn't say why it is that you know
Cain's sacrifice is refused
and to a certain extent it's possible
that that doesn't really matter what
really matters is only the fact that
it's not the right sacrifice and that
sometimes this is not necessarily
that we don't necessarily always know
you know what is the right sacrifice or
what isn't that's possible but in the
story of Prometheus it is suggested that
there is a kind of trickery in the
sacrifice that is Prometheus tries to
trick Zeus by offering the least good
you know the not the best fruit but the
the worst fruits but that of course if
you do that you know you can't trick the
gods and that is what prompts Zeus to
remove the fire from the humans in the
story of Cain and Abel
it is what prompts Kane to become
resentful he doesn't offer the proper
sacrifice he becomes resentful but then
he founds a city
and so it's very important to see the
relationship that in the story of
Prometheus the idea that there's a
relationship between
improper sacrifice or a presumptuous
sacrifice maybe is the best way to
understand it you know a kind of trying
to trick reality or trying to to not be
forthright and true about what is real
and artificing you know we even use it
you can understand that we use the
notion artificer we say that something
is artificial because we see it to a
certain extent as a a fake or a lesser
version of that which is the true thing
so in the very story of Cain now you can
understand and in the story of
Prometheus that there's a relationship
between the improper sacrifice and that
which pretends to be something else
and the artificing and how technology
although it is an increasing of power
it is something like a an imitation of
of the natural processes a possibly a
let's say a um an increase but an
increase in which the essence of
something is diminished as it is it add
as it increases its power so we can see
that of course in the story of Cain and
Abel that is that as
Kane increases the power and as his
Generations increase in power and in
making weapons and different aspects of
that
then he is also increasing the curse now
in the story of Cain and Abel you can
understand that even as the Arts that is
the artificial version of natural
patterns that are imitated by humans and
so there are natural patterns that kind
of reveal themselves to us and now
humans will imitate those patterns
whether it's music whether it is by
different different you know images
making images that resemble something
else making buildings that have the
let's say the the proportions natural
proportions of a of a of a natural space
but now
in closing and kind of creating a shell
around it in order to to protect Cain
and Abel so you can kind of you get this
intuition of what it is that what are
these themes dealing with
and you can also see for example in the
story of hephestos the same type of
pattern which is that Festus is
presumptuous he tries to do something
which is unacceptable he tries to raise
himself up at the level of his father by
having a relationship with his own
mother and because of that he gets
thrown out of paradise just like
Prometheus is let's say thrown out of
the presence of the god chained to the
to the Rock there's the punishment
and that punishment will lead hephaestos
to create the uh the the artifices that
he creates now in the story of
hephaestos you get an even better sense
of what's going on because in the story
it says that hephestos they're they're
two virgins or the different strains one
is that when Zeus threw him out of uh of
Olympus he fell and then became lame and
there are other versions where he was
already lame before and that is possibly
one of the reasons why Zeus threw him
out to a certain extent it doesn't
matter which one of those versions you
you
you look at what's important to us
understand is that there's a
relationship between weakness and
artifice there's a relationship between
the fact of not having self-sufficient
power within ourselves and having to add
this power from the outside like the
garments of skin
um in order to increase one's power
and so if in Adam and Eve the fall and
the The Fallout of the garden makes them
weaker and because of that they have to
supplement their power the same thing
happens to Cain as he's chased out
further out from the the the garden he
becomes weaker and fragile and and is in
danger and so has to create the city to
compensate for his weakness you see that
of course in the in the story of
hephestos now what's interesting is that
you can see kind of all these themes
coming together that there's a
relationship between presumption
a relationship between presumption and
then also weakness maybe even
presumption in weakness
and that this is what
let's say brings about the the
civilization itself and brings about
technology as a means to supplement that
that
um that weakness and so it's very
interesting to notice how if you look at
the different stories you can see these
weave patterns they're not exactly the
same you know it's those all these
stories are not the same but they have
enough elements that are similar to help
us see how a through line of what it is
that these stories are talking about
because they they are using different
analogies to bring about
similar conclusion or to help us see
similar things
so you can understand for example that
the passions that Prometheus deals with
is cycle of passions is related to even
the causing of technology and the desire
for more power that technology brings
about it's also related to the fact that
Cain when he is resentful of his brother
and angry that he his sacrifice is not
accepted that God warns him right that
sin is at his door and is watching him
and is there to devour him and so so
this is of course related to Prometheus
who's in this cycle of of emotions or
cycle of passions which could also be
seen as a as a cycle of sin and that
cycle of sin is related of course to
hephiso's transgression which is a a
sick circular transgression as well that
is wanting to have intercourse with your
own mother breaking the normal causality
which will then lead him to becoming an
artificer so all of these things are
related and so
what's important is to see that at least
at the outset in the laboratory of
symbolism as we're looking at the
different stories and how they relate to
each other and how the analogies
come together and how the analogies show
mirror each other what
what we don't have at the outset is a
kind of uh moralism is a kind of lesson
the lesson isn't there quite as quite at
the outset you have to be able to
distill the imagery and to get a sense
of what it is that's going on and then
later then you can apply it and you can
apply it in different ways because you
have a sense of what what deep deep
pattern these stories are bringing to
the fore and so you can then use the
story of Cain and Abel to talk about
resentment you can use the story of Cain
and Abel to talk about how the more you
increase your power the the more there
is danger that you will also increase
the let's say the curse
or the let's say the consequences of
that power in the world
and there's so you can use it in
different ways you can there are
different aspects that you can bring
about once you start to kind of
understand the the story
um and so there's another little
interesting aspect in terms of circular
causality that is there in the story of
Cain and Abel which is not in the Bible
but appears in later Traditions that
have to do with hephaestos wanting to
have a relationship with his own mother
so when we get to the last part for
example of the story of lamech when it
says he you know he says to his wives
hear my voice why Islamic listen to my
speech where I've killed a man for
wounding me even a young man for hurting
me if Cain shall be shall be Avenged
Sevenfold and lamech seventy Sevenfold
it's very strange and mysterious text
because he doesn't tell you who did he
kill what is he talking about who's he
referring to none of this makes sense
and so of course these these cryptic
texts uh especially the very early ones
they will give rise to Legends and then
if you understand all these analogies
that I've been bringing up you can
understand why the Legends look the way
they do the Legends related to these
stories often are a way to explicit what
it is that's going on
and so the with how the the way the
legend goes which is based on different
um pseudographic texts both in the
Christian sources and in the Jewish
sources as well you see it in Rashi but
you also see it in in the um
I think what is I forget what it's
called The Book of Adam and Eve this I
think it's that that's the book the The
Legend goes that
lamech became old and was became blind
and so as he was old and blind he was
taken by his son tubal Kane to go
hunting so tubal cane brought him
hunting
and so as they were hunting they saw in
the distance something which they
thought or that tubal cane thought to be
an animal and when lamic shot the arrow
it turned out that that if that that uh
character was actually Kane and so
lamech kills Kane but then when he finds
out that he's killed his own ancestor he
gets extremely angry and then kills two
Bill Kane as well and so he kills Kane
he kills two boat Kane and then that
brings him to say that he will be
Avenged 77-fold and so what's
interesting is that you see both the
increase in violence you also see the
circular causality where lamech is
killing both his ancestor and his son
right we we talked about the problem of
revolutionary revolutionary myth where
you have Zeus you know you have Saturn
that that uh the Kronos who castrates
his father and then has to eat his
children in order to to to stop the
revolution you see the same story in
some versions of the story of Zeus where
you know he ends up killing his father
and he or he ends up killing his
children so you have this problem of the
Revolutionary story and how it tends to
self-devour and self and and self you
know and and break apart and so you have
a version of this in this legend about
about Cain and Abel where ultimately the
process that Cain enters into this
prophets this process of supplementarity
based on the killing of his own brother
leads to a place where he is killed by
his descendant and that descendant also
kills his own son and so he is left in a
position an impossible position of
tragedy where the entire line of Cain
self devours in the end and leads to
this increase
in violence which is represented in the
idea of to of oflamic saying you know uh
if cage will be Avenged Sevenfold then I
will be Avenged 77 fold
um
so
as you kind of understand the structure
of these stories and you you will be
able hopefully to see that
that even the legends that get
associated with the biblical story
they're not usually not arbitrary of
course they have less Force than the
text themselves but it but if you can
get the pattern then when you look at
those Legends you'll be able to
understand them uh more easily
so I hope this has been enlightening and
I know for some of you it might be
frustrating because I'm leaving it at
least in this case into all these
analogies and bringing you up into the
laboratory of symbolism and uh be
interesting to see how you can take all
these references and links that I
brought together and then apply them to
specific context and so I thank
everybody for your attention and I'll
talk to you very soon